IAN LAKE: Welcome to Android
Development Patterns, where
we help you build better apps.
I'm Ian Lake.
Let's get to work.
Let's think about how you
navigate through an app.
You navigate to a detailed
view from the parent view,
or you can navigate
between sibling views.
That's where tabs and
ViewPagers come in.
So what is a ViewPager?
That's what controls the actual
swiping between different pages
of content.
ViewPager gets its content
from a PagerAdapter.
This could be a
generic view-- one
for each page-- or
whole fragments,
if you use a
FragmentPagerAdapter
or FragmentStatePagerAdapter.
keeps each fragment
it creates in memory, making
it lightning fast to switch
between already loaded tabs.
However, this can get
expensive, memory-wise,
if you have a large
number of fragments.
Something
FragmentStatePagerAdapter
solves by destroying and
recreating fragments as needed,
only saving the state.
There isn't a lot
to a PagerAdapter.
You'll need to override
getCount to return
the number of pages you have.
Then, in the case of a
FragmentPagerAdapter,
you'll need to
implement getItem,
which returns the fragment
associated with each position.
Here, we'll just do a
simple switch statement,
selecting the right
fragment for each position.
But you have the flexibility
to use any approach you want.
The other thing we
might want to override
is getPageTitle, returning a
string describing each page.
Why would you want a page title?
Well, those page titles
will be really helpful
if you want to have some tabs
associated with your ViewPager.
Tabs give users a
great way to see
exactly what those pages
contain without having
to scroll through each one.
They also allow users
to jump between pages
by tapping on a tab.
The TabLayout class, part of the
Android Design Support Library,
makes it easy to implement tabs,
with all the material design
styling.
And it's backward
compatible to Android 2.1.
Let's hook everything together.
First, we need to
hook our ViewPager up
to a PagerAdapter
using setAdapter.
Then, hooking up a TabLayout
is just a single method
setupWithViewPager.
With just that, you get tabs
from the PagerAdapter's titles.
And swiping through pages
will change the tabs,
and tapping on tabs will change
the pages-- as you'd expect.
Get started with the
TabLayout and ViewPagers
by adding the Design Library.
Be sure to check out
the design guidelines
and the detailed training docs.
Thanks for joining me here on
Android Development Patterns.
Use tabs and ViewPagers
to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]